Колишній директор ЦРУ і чотиризірковий генерал
Девід Петреус є постійним гостем DW News.
Генерале Петреус, дуже дякую, що знайшли час на початку цього вирішального року.
2024 рік є роком президентських виборів у Сполучених Штатах.
Багато людей у всьому світі запитують: що буде, якщо переможе Трамп?
Що, на вашу думку, він зробив би щодо України? Чи спробував би він якось змінити ситуацію з Путіним?
Це можливо?
Чесно кажучи, я не знаю. У Вашингтоні є багато інших органів,
у тому числі обидві палати Конгресу, в яких є сильна двопартійна більшість,
яка підтримує продовження підтримки України та виділення їй коштів.
І я думаю, що за наступні тижні ми побачимо, наприклад, що питання в нашій Палаті представників
будуть вирішені. Звичайно, те, що вони намагаються зробити,
— це використати частину цього як важіль впливу,
щоб змусити адміністрацію до певної міри,
до деяких змін у політиці та інших дій для покращення безпеки нашого південного кордону,
що, на мою думку, є гідною метою, враховуючи проблеми,
які ми бачимо там, безпрецедентну кількість нелегальних іммігрантів,
які перетинають цей кордон.
Але я думаю, що це буде вирішено.
Питання в тому, чи це буде наступного тижня, чи за тиждень після цього, чи пізніше.
Але будуть дуже значні додаткові дозволи та асигнування для України,
а також для поповнення наших власних запасів.
Тож це буде незабаром, і ми пройдемо весь шлях до інавгурації наступної адміністрації.
Чесно кажучи, 10 місяців, які очікують нас попереду
— це ціла вічність в американській політиці.
Я вважаю, що дуже передчасно починати спекулювати про те, що конкретно може зробити
той чи інший кандидат, якщо він повернеться на посаду.
Але востаннє, коли він був на посаді, він намагався реально вийти з НАТО.
Що ви про це думаєте як чотиризірковий генерал?
Що з цього приводу подумає військове керівництво?
І чи можуть вони спробувати чинити перешкоди цьому бажанню?
Ну, вже прийнято законодавство, яке не дозволяє президенту виводити нас із НАТО.
Тож я вважаю, що на цей момент це неактуальне питання.
Проте НАТО будується на довірі.
Якби він знову погрожував вийти з НАТО,
хіба сама по собі ця загроза не послабила б Альянс величезною мірою?
Ну, знаєте, коли президент Трамп був на посаді, я казав,
що ви повинні читати твіти, тому що це невідредаговані висловлювання президента Сполучених Штатів.
Але потім слідкувати за військом, грошима і політикою.
І фактично під час його адміністрації ми повернули бронетанкову бригаду до Європи
вперше після того, як її вивели за кілька років до того - мені здається, під час адміністрації Обами.
Ми ухвалили нову структуру НАТО і так далі,
підтримували низку інших ініціатив, які фактично покращили позицію НАТО.
Тому все це було здійснено.
І знову ж таки, пам’ятайте, що у Вашингтоні є дуже сильна підтримка обох партій щодо подальшої участі в НАТО.
Але також варто визнати, що кожен окремий президент,
включно з тими двома, при яких я служив чотиризірковим командувачем у війні,
був стурбований і публічно висловився про те,
що деякі союзники по НАТО не платять своєї частки.
І тому було так приємно бачити, як Німеччина після Zeitenwende
або так званого "переходу у нову епоху" взяла на себе зобов’язання не лише досягти 1,5% ВВП
на оборону, але й перевищити 2%.
І ми з нетерпінням чекаємо, що це буде реалізовано через бундестаг.
Це дуже, дуже обнадійливо.
Це четверта економіка у світі, яка так суттєво зростає, тож це дуже важлива заява.
І наостанок я хотів би лише зазначити,
що Європа зобов’язалася подвоїти допомогу,
яку Сполучені Штати пообіцяли для України.
Зараз не тільки надано більше, а й заплановано більше щодо допомоги у сфері безпеки, ніж пообіцяли США.
А США пообіцяли виділити понад 44 мільярди доларів, як ви знаєте.
Тож закладено набагато більше.
І це, на мою думку, є доречним, коли йдеться про економічну, фінансову та гуманітарну допомогу.
Зрештою, це питання європейської безпеки.
Це підводить мене до наступного запитання.
Чи справді у США вистачить стратегічного терпіння, щоб підтримувати Україну?
Я думаю, що так. І я думаю, що в нас є для цього можливості.
Я зазначив, що США виділили понад 44 мільярди доларів на підтримку безпеки,
але це з витрат на оборону за два роки, які загалом перевищують 1,7 трильйона.
Тож це дуже доступно. І знову ж таки:
Україна не просить американців чи солдатів будь-якої країни НАТО воювати і вмирати за свою країну.
Цим займаються їхні юнаки та дівчата у формі.
Це їхня війна за незалежність, і вони визнають її своєю боротьбою за своє виживання.
Чи справді в України був шанс виграти
цей наступ без західних винищувачів?
Оглядаючись назад, я думаю, що ні.
Знову ж таки, наша власна доктрина вимагає переваги в повітрі.
Не просто паритету в повітрі, а переваги в повітрі,
щоб подолати такі значні оборонні перешкоди,
які Росія встановила на півдні України.
Ходять чутки чи розмови, що можливо більша частина України приєднається до НАТО,
а решта залишиться окупованою Росією.
Як ви вважаєте, це можливий чи ймовірний сценарій?
Я не знаю, чи це ймовірно.
Я знаю, що це один зі сценаріїв, які люди досліджують.
Я схильний думати, що звільнення справді всього, що окупувала Росія,
включаючи Крим і Донбас, дійсно необхідне, як з оборонної точки зору, так і для того,
щоб зменшити територію, яку Росія може зайняти.
Я маю на увазі, що фронт зараз дуже, дуже великий.
Це значно більше, ніж було на Донбасі.
Але Донбас також необхідний з економічної точки зору,
якщо ми справді хочемо процвітання України.
Але я знаю, що є багато різних сценаріїв,
які люди розглядають, що можуть певним чином залучити НАТО.
Звичайно, членство в ЄС також було б дуже і дуже бажаним.
А далі виділення дуже значних коштів і те,
що можна назвати якимось сучасним планом Маршалла,
щоб допомогти Україні продовжити свою реконструкцію.
Що є найбільшою загрозою для України зараз?
Що ж, я думаю, що є низка можливих проблем.
Найбільше, на мою думку, зараз є ймовірність того, що Росія може одного дня справді розбити антидроновий,
протиповітряний і протиракетний захист і завдати такої шкоди українській інфраструктурі,
яку вона намагалася завдати з самого початку, але так і не досягла.
Я думаю, що це може бути дуже нищівним.
Це також може підірвати моральний дух.
І тому я кажу, що вкрай необхідно якнайшвидше надіслати їм усе,
що можемо, щоб унеможливити таку ситуацію.
Чи є тиск США на Зеленського, щоб він уклав угоду з Росією,
щоб принаймні заморозити війну вздовж поточної лінії фронту?
Не дуже, тому що я не думаю, що вони… Я не думаю, що є такий тиск.
Звісно, одна справа, коли люди вивчають чи думають про те, як цю війну можна закінчити.
Але адміністрація від самого початку сказала: нічого про Україну без України.
І я вірю, що вони дотримувалися цієї великої ідеї.
Що буде через пів року?
В Україні? Це залежить.
Це явно залежить від низки різних факторів, які гратимуть роль.
Це залежить від того, наскільки вдасться українцям створити додаткові сили.
Залежить від того, наскільки добре західні країни, країни НАТО,
США справляються з наданням того, що генерал Залужний назвав необхідним.
Це залежить від того, чи може Росія продовжувати генерувати сили зі свого боку.
Зазначу, що вона ніколи не проводила повну мобілізацію.
Вона намагається захистити населення Москви, Санкт-Петербурга тощо.
І, як правило, вербує сили із більш сільських районів, а не з дітей еліти,
не кажучи вже про в’язниці та приватних військових підрядників.
Я справді вважаю, що це протистояння правильного і неправильного.
Я вважаю, що в інтересах країн НАТО та всіх західних країн переконатися,
що Росія не досягне успіху, а Україна зможе звільнити всю свою територію,
приєднатися до ЄС, приєднатися до НАТО
та забезпечити відновлення країни.
Дякую вам.
Навзаєм.